there are many different treatments for
diabetes I'll just use myself as a case
study one of the things I did to myself
is you know I measure my blood sugar at
different times during the day and my
blood sugar this morning was 116 okay
and my blood sugar at about 5 o'clock
this afternoon will probably be in the
high 80s or 90 my blood sugar after I
have a meal might go up to 160 170 okay
and it shouldn't go that high okay
and some mornings like a couple of days
ago my blood sugar was 146 it's just too
high okay and that reflects two things
what I ate the night before but the
second thing is the one that's my
problem which is gluconeogenesis
luke'll neurogenesis technically means
new synthesis of glucose from non
carbohydrate precursors for example I
could take the amino acid aspartate and
I could find a path by which I could
convert that into glucose I could take
lactate and I could convert it into
glucose
okay so during the day you know I used
my glucose and I stay active and I walk
around I ride my bike and so on so my
glucose level you know it's pretty
reasonable by the time I go to bed but
then at night when I stop moving around
a lot
this gluconeogenesis process continues
in me and that's what causes my blood
sugar to go up that the medicine I take
is called metformin it has a number of
targets but one of them is one of the
enzymes in the called Pepsi que pyruvate
carboxylase that's in the
gluconeogenesis another word actually so
we all have dinner like say you know six
to nine o'clock at night we go to bed
and we're there are certain organs in
the body
you know the brain our red blood cells
that require glucose they can't work
with anything else
so gluconeogenesis by principally the
liver provides a constant stream of
glucose to these organs that absolutely
require it like our brain now when we go
to sleep at night you know as time gets
longer and longer and longer after the
meal our there's going to be the glucose
level is going to our natural glucose
level is going to start to fall off and
the liver then compensates by increasing
the amount of gluconeogenesis in order
to keep our blood glucose at about a
hundred well we're not eating what I do
during during the night is is to take
this drug that will prevent the switch
to produce more and more sugar by by
gluconeogenesis